[Musique]
et
à
on
[Musique]
il ya bien apprécié ton frère il a
peut-être peur d'arriver en retard à
marcillac pour la brigade la brigade ne
commencera pas sans lui c'est lui qui
amène les temps aux abords
oui mais tu vas va aborder cette plaque
à la brigade
ben voyons ma mère je sais très bien que
je suis garde de chef de la réserve du
vaccarès donc de service 24 heures sur
24 il a brival est une fête de gardians
que en garde mais tu avant tout un
gardien à ton père l'était et ton grand
père temps gelé épouse il était aussi
face au taureau un trident est plus
utile qu'une plaque aux frais d art chef
de poids que l'étendard moi je me marre
aux bonjour fanette bonjour madame
geoff hann est finie et nous le travail
ça nous a toujours fait courir le sapeur
à marquer comme il se fait grâce inouïe
vous devinez pas pourquoi à ce soir
manet ou les autres suivent
avec une fille et ses 200 l'âge mais
cette fille c'est la fille de perez ça
vous dit rien non perez le riziculteur
qui a interdit à cette pauvre petite de
parler à frédéric et qu'il avait
surveillé par de marque que mal alors
moi à ma rose j'ai l'impression que
c'est un bris mode saas ont réussi dans
ce pour ce qui est de la fille de son
âge mais pense que de la bagarre c'est
pas du miel comme ça fait peur pour moi
il ya que deux choses qui me font peur
la mare aux c'est le travail et l'eau à
10 euros pour la bagarre aux enfers
je suis là têtus et même un peu là ça je
me demande comment tu peux encore arrivé
avait trotté bottes avec un vent de
pareils nous apprenait que je n'ai pas
de ventre jeudi restera à lyon
[Musique]
il
mario à lyon avec toi quoi vite mais non
mais non y'a pas le feu c'est pas le
moment de dire tout quoi virginie via le
filet tu sais ce que dit son père l'a
quittée pas des yeux et empêché l'acteur
frédéric et alors et alors elle va le
rejoindre à la brigade de marsillargues
et un gros malin allé voir mon dieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
il commence à l'égard des pays s'amusait
de leytron non pas les prendre
l'apéritif la famille virginie virginie
annaba tu crois que son père leur a
laissé venir
elle me l'avait promis c'est que les
femmes promettent c'est qu'avoir la
mienne en tout cas si tu la vois tu neil
asher
allez zou
[Applaudissements]
au pire jeudi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des amis comme ça toi bagarre ouais
surtout qu'elle n'est pas moi qui me
barre
aller vaquer à tommasini à gauche non
non à droite
allanon jamais de la vie voilà je le
connais rien c'est à gauche pour nos
propres
je ne dis pas de bêtises juliette à
droite rappelle ça se discute
et non ça se discute pas eva cette élite
assis et moi je te dis que non objective
et on en parlait dans l'eau et sont
marocaines
comment tu m'a appelé marocaine bistrot
non c'est pas le mont de masse troqué
qui va blesser c'est la façon dont de la
pensée doit le retirer tout de suite pas
gabon touristique
qu'est ce que tu dis ça qui m'a plu et
couteaux julie et je vais me fâcher 10
au samedi andy en gros il vaut mieux
regarder les autres
damon fatigué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des passagers et essai ni à gauche ni à
droite qui l'a frappé regardez à me
plaît au mieux alors comme ça se vend
les échelons
[Musique]
olé
jusqu'où
il ne reste plus qu'une chose à faire
[Musique]
alors moi
batigère cette fois et on s'est mis
ensuite ils ont tous les frais seront
pris peur de cogner pour attaquer il
faut absolument que je trouve que l'on
roule dans la boue
non c'est pour mon pauvre pour ce qui
est de voir moi je peux faire ma
naissance et c'est à propos fleuris
c'est pas une option l'homme ondh et
quelque chose d'un petit pont et touahri
baguette
j'ai une solution fruits dit toujours
allant jusque chez lui à félix il a
toujours la clairette offrait il a
déridé ce que dit on y va
[Musique]
on
ophélie tu as
au regard de qui là les gardiens mario
canahuati année ils ont des amis chez
félix hommage à mario aller mario bien
les maillots
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aux fins de riz est ce qui se passe est
arrivé trop tard eh bien il se pense que
le vieux phoenix a eu des visiteurs qui
part à s'être pressés on a à peine le
temps de bavarder
on dirait qu'ils ont été plus bavard que
vous j'aurais voulu d'ivoire tient ils
sont sortis de ses phénix comme une
avalanche comment ça va là bas
allons-y
c'est tout restera là et c'est pas des
touristes c'est les hommes de perez
ouais le parisien celui qui achètent et
les masses pointu aux rivières et sans
doute de faire encore un mauvais coup on
ne vous entre les gendarmes vous voyez
le mal partout et moi un coup vient cet
écart morin ça peut pas nous faire le
mal gré allez venez gendarmes de vivre
bon ben je ne m'attend
et par les étangs
[Musique]
cadets au pas lent de montblanc
un mafieux sans seul je monte chantons
ma chanson du band
ban
[Musique]
en une ils ont peut-être ont tuer ce
pauvre
puneet félix alix dix huit de nos deux
langues ou d'un fermoir de l'eau je
m'appelle oulémas mort et tu vois que tu
dois toujours transporter nos futurs ou
de quelque chose sur toi en cas
d'accident échelle c'est bien d'arriver
aux salaires en montagne le canada est
un pays plat qu'est ce qui se passe ici
il se passe que je suis un vieux clients
tu crois comme les commandes
si jamais seulement 20 ans de moins
genre on va montrer de quel bois je me
chauffe on a tous été un magasin
mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils m'ont
fait regardes tu tombes des dix où es tu
te plains qu'est ce que tu veux ma femme
était malade je n'ai pas d'argent pour
la soie nîmois annoncé accepter de ram
intéresse vous avez vendu votre maison
ma maison tu veux dire ma cabane fait
évidemment n'est pas joli joli vin et je
puis que je l' ai plus jamais trouvé si
belle nous va-t-on aller maintenant je
veux pas le voir qui n'est pas seul mais
en tout cas on peut pas laisser
fiançailles faut reprendre le papier
perez tu as raison je vais lui dire deux
mots tout à l'heure mais tout à l'heure
j'ai pris par surprise mais maintenant
quoi moi tu me connais ça me pas bon
cette fois c'est moi qui vais les
chercher de terre battue va pas venir et
d'y aller tout seul chez terrain tu vas
te faire massacrer
c'est un repère de voyous je déteste
le fatah qui auraient fraudé rit pas
fait pas fait attention
[Musique]
bon et maintenant on va aller téléphoner
chez julliard et et alors on va prendre
un petit médicaments deux petits
médicamenteux c'est parce que vous
n'êtes pas encore prête et du travail
vous pour un grand moment un réseau plus
on serait derrière cette allure et la
pléthore des voitures demoiselle vous
avez dit que frédéric et état jeune
homme sérieux si tu les as sérieux n'est
pas avoir de rendre visite aux
demoiselles la crise du logement serait
vite résolu vers l europe et julien
[Musique]
c'est fait mais on ne lit me fait mal à
jouer leur choix redit que vous preniez
ce labrador que la mère de dieu gaza
marché floral et doivent être vaincus
one du monde comme un deuil
on prend tous âges arrivait on va guette
aux fans et aux séries juillet comme tu
vois
alors messieurs les gardes fédéraux ont
ce problème messieurs les gendarmes
les gardes fédéraux de ce problème
jamais il vaque de zani siège tant
défaut et que celui qui est pas de
jetons ici tu tourne la manivelle alors
demande moi le docteur - la saison
téléphone appareil inventé par graham
bell permet de parler à distance alors
que te débrouiller tout seul parce que
moi j'ai du travail
je me demande si dans cet établissement
on traite la clientèle avait tout le
respect voulu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour virginie vous avez eu des ennuis
avec franck et mario non nous bavardions
c'est moi vous venez voir non c'est
votre père de mal à propos je vous ai
attendu autre jour la ferrade de la
faune en aviez promis de venir net paris
je suis désolé je n'ai pas plus j'ai eu
du travail
un dimanche vous savez dans la réserve
il n'y a pas de dimanche virginie
quoi qu'il arrive on n'aurait jamais
l'air d'unique je vois ce soir vous
savez que votre père ne veut pas depuis
quand êtes-vous content de son opinion
depuis je vous connais bon il faut que
j'y aille maintenant je vais lui parler
je voulais lui parler de nous non d
autres hors voirie g
eh les gars regardez qui est ce qui
vient nous voir monsieur le garde de
chef de la réserve en personne
ray perdez votre chemin à moins que
rooney quelque chose me dit oui cela
seul yoyo rien à cacher un méga on
pourrait paraître comme vous voudrez
alors victor perez
vous êtes un [ __ ]
et les gars est nommé entendu je suis un
[ __ ] connais bien et à penser que
puis-je faire pour vous être agréable
prendre l'avion pour la chine ne plus
jamais remettre les pieds en canard
mon cher frédéric vous êtes iris un
autre que vous me parle ainsi sommes
fâchés mais où
c'est bien que vous plaisantez je ne
plaisante pas perez reprenez votre
argent
les rangs des mois le papier que vous
avez fait signer de force à félix rester
tranquille vous autres commencent à tout
à l'heure
raté mon petit
a plaisanté avec lui
c'est trop difficile
quand j'ai débuté à 14 ans sur le quai à
marseille j'avais même pas de chaussures
ce que j'ai aujourd'hui j'ai durement
gagné et si je cherche à agrandir mes
terres que vous cherchez à grandir vos
terres ça ne me dérange pas ce qui me
dérange par contre c'est que vous
forciez la même mes amis mais forcément
de personnes m'ont de terre du vieux
félix m'intéresse parce qu'il est au
bord de l'étang
je lui ai payé 20 fois son prix il m'a
signe un papier en bonne et due forme
donc j'ai l'intention de me servir et un
jour j'en aurai également un signe et de
vous n'y comptez pas question de temps
autre masse est une enclave dans le mia
by me gêne
j'en suis ravi me vous rapporte rue ils
vous coûte de l'argent vous est même
obligé d'aller travailler ailleurs pour
le compte y est
- victor perez journal offre une jolie
100 gardez là ni moi ni mon man sam à
vendre et puis je ne suis pas venu ici
pour parler de moi
écoutez perez vous n'êtes pas plus
mauvais qu'un autre possédait déjà des
milliers d'hectares
alors laissez ce bout de terrain au
vieux félix vous voulez vous qu'il a est
maintenant en chine cieux ce papier
parfaitement sûr non pas avec votre
conscience
nous en reparlerons quand vous voudrez
non pas de cancer mais je crois que il a
besoin d'une bonne petite leçon
r tu n'as pas le droit ici je t'ai les
droits mais un génie même celui de te
dire de ne pas s'occuper de ça rentre à
la maison a vite compris qu'on ne
l'imaginé vous devez aller dans votre
chambre
c'est un nombre de votre père et je suis
chargé de faire exécuter comme toujours
le sujet par le régisseur de son mas
c'est tout normalement à virginie votre
père vous avez une galerie de robinson
frédéric et vous l'avez rendue quand
même oui gervais base aujourd'hui en
tout cas enrico oui mais c'est pas en
forme il l'a sortir sous son plein
prétexte bien monsieur paul vous croyez
malin mais je sortirai quand même il
frédéric s'occupera de vous pourront
voir ces noms que nous occupons de lui
mcn auteur d'un livre est très bon mais
je ne t'entends
mais par les temps
le blog
ro
pourquoi l'an ii
marqueurs censeurs
je monte chansons
ma chanson préférée du camp autrui
le mans
[Musique]
on
donc
c'est pour tous
apple le docteur non gendarmes les
gardes fédéraux c'est solide
alors c'est pour qui c'est une véritable
enquête policière que vous faites c'est
un peu la curiosité
alors tu es trop curieux jaune a clos
alors ça répond pas c'est ça ça ne
répond pas écoute moi même
bah oui c'est ça oui ça sonne mais ça
répond pas ne répond pas alors que les
foules en face de chez lui la revoir des
amis
des fois ils ont deux des consultations
au sahb a perdu des touristes non je les
ai mis un terme à 18,1 sûr que ton
appareil fonctionne bien
qu'est-ce que tu insinue que mon
matériel défectueux
je n'insinue pas alors j'affirme et
voilà comment on traite un honnête
commerçant on met à la disposition de la
clientèle matériel coûteux moderne
perfectionner et comme récompense
on se fait engueuler et bien des
injustices comme celle là moi ça me
laisse muet ou ce que vous tentez
l'épreuve
parce que ça répond toujours pas fait
alors c'est ma conception du tourisme
qui te fait rire aux gendarmes n'ont
jury pour autre chose
ah oui et peut-on savoir auquel nous
sommes peut-être curieux mais des fois
ça sert par exemple je sais pourquoi le
docteur il ne répond pas connu q
pourquoi parce qu'il n'est pas chez lui
tu es sûr que tu te jure mais ne pas
trop en ce moment et je sais aussi
pourquoi le docteur n'est pas chez lui
et pourquoi parce qu'il est ailleurs
ailleurs la base mais shanxi bouyxou le
petit à les aurions en se dépêchant tu
peut l'attraper avant qu'il reparte
je veux que le trampoline rayons non le
docteur tu peux pas le dire tout de
suite non on ne me l'a pas demandé
10ème sans connaître de plus beaux trucs
les gendarmes et que les gendarmes mais
ça me paraît difficile hein tu as voulu
explique tim gendarmes ça peut n'être
pas ça fait le tour du pin saint sava ya
même des fois où je me demande si les
gendarmes il n'est pas nuisible sur un
terrain commun
le doryphore la gale du pommier où le
moustique est encore le moustique
il est parfois très utile et puis que le
tourisme doryphores lui à l'origine
était stationné ella ella ella virtuose
entre temps sur un qu'est ce que vous
êtes en train de se nouer
nous ne nous savions tous affirmé c'est
très grave devrait de toute façon
j'adore ça vous regarde pas c'est une
conversation privée samana vous n'avez
pas le droit de vous introduire à
l'intérieur mieux en mieux
nous avons compris c'est par contre si
tu ne marques pas ça sur mon compte est
allé rate jamais revoir mais ce que les
gendarmes et merci je me demande bien ce
que je voulais dire eh bien moi je vais
te le dire depuis que l'éducation et les
nationales et bien le super à les
gendarmes voient pas ce que le tourisme
je vous dis on s'attend pas à l'école
francine sert la mienne les forces de
l'ordre sont empreintes de définir
enrico oui mademoiselle virginie
ouvre-moi ville je me suis fait mal
c'est impossible
monsieur paul mall interdit aux mais
juste une minute alliage ofen maria rien
vient vite il mort penses tu il a la
tête dure
non ça va bon écoute tu le bayonne et
tulle ans ferme à clé d'accord vendredi
allons soit sage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m'est avis que ça va barder on va voir
ce qui se passe lors ce qui peut se
passer
ne nous regarde pas tant que nous
n'avons pas été saisis d'une requête
régulière non je viens toit de sa
gendarmes
un gendarme nord qui n'existe pas bien
brigadier allez suivez moi un métier que
je fais c'est une profession bien
briller car c'est le mois
[Musique]
docteur alors c'est sérieux on y va ça
demande réflexion
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce qui se passe on est
arrivé à la haye sera bonne et ils ont
l'air de se plaire par ici un os pour
moi maintenant à vous avez pas parlé
c'est pour ça qu'ils aimeraient aussi
pressé marie d'un peu plus il nous cache
le véhicule et ouais il va demeurer au
plus dans cette affaire au céleri
bon bah il faut la sortir de la nasse
ces chalets sont allés au je pense je
dirais qu'ils auraient pu mourir là ça
m'a fait lire de toutefois sans toi tu
ne pouvais faire que de soi et au rayon
c'est toi cash de déménagement on m'a
aidé donc commencé par balancer la
chaise les tables étaient ensuite il se
sent prêt balancé par l'armoire mais
tout ça c'est excellent pour le coeur de
cette pauvre femme aux flics ne tient
pas c'est nous dit c'est nous frédéric
de baguettes et et le docteur les autres
sont partis très bien rentrés ont fait
démocratie
je suis croyant cette fatigue et chef et
non sous la roue crevée
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait j'ai effectué
l'arrêt porte ah bon yacef
voilà il ne s'est pas uni des chefs
c'est une voiture américaine
oui oui on y va chef mais où veux tu
allais paisible ils en arrivent de tous
les côtés c'est lui la droite sur la
gauche et où veux tu qu'on aille au
milieu c'est pas bête
merci chef qu'est ce qu'on risque rien
chef et bien allons-y alors on peut
passer par ap alors ce qu'elle a le plus
besoin c'est de calme avec vous trois
desservis je vais la faire emmener à
l'hôpital elle peut pas rester au bo lui
lui les solides
seulement il peut pas rester ici on peut
déposer le mont masse le maire monsieur
s'en occuperont bon je passerai pas
encore mais c'était prix même de nous
n'est pas une fiole de quelque chose là
dedans par hasard dit pourquoi ces
malades
non mais je sais que ça vient ça et s'il
ya eu de la bagarre est alors de toute
façon c'est trop tard ah c'est le drame
de la gendarmerie nous arrivons toujours
trop tard après le drame e ou après
l'accident
on vient jamais nous chercher à la nous
sommes bien méconnu et oui brigadier
alors mon petit pas d'attendrissement
faisons notre devoir patrouillant à vos
ordres et gagner
baxter dans l'ivresse tout est bon mais
je ne m'attends
mais par les étranges
le flambeau
[Musique]
au ballon
un marqueur sans ce jeu monte chansons
ma chanson préférée du camp
[Musique]
le mans
on
[Musique]